well let's return now to the budget what
will the Chancellor's own MPS wanted to
hear from him well Harriet Baldwin is
with me she's a conservative MP and
chair of the treasury select committee
um thank you very much for coming in and
Jeremy Hunters perhaps ended up with a
little bit more Headroom than he might
have expected when um we were thinking
about where this budget might be back in
the Autumn
um are we in the right place to be
spending huge sums of money on things
like child care and defense
we'll see what the figures are later but
he has been lucky over the course of the
winter because of course when he
budgeted in November he was expecting
Energy prices to be higher than they
have been and so what I expect him to do
today and in fact one of the measures
has just been announced is to extend
that price cap for households for a bit
longer that's been worth about 700
pounds for households over the winter
should be worth about another 160 pounds
to households by the extension of course
that's really been helpful in
tackling this big economic challenge
that the chancellor faces which is the
rate of inflation and he will want to do
things today I think that reduce
inflation he will want to do things that
cut debt overall and he will want to do
things that grow the economy and
there'll be a real Focus I expect today
on growth but in in terms of the nuts
and bolts of the money potentially
public sector pay Rises up by 5.5 fuel
Duty freeze 5 billion Energy bill help
that we just talked about that could
cost four to five billion 5 billion
defense pension changes green investment
over two decades 20 billion the country
is still not in in an entirely stable
economic State can we afford this
well I think what he will do is he will
make sure that at the end when he sits
down uh the numbers do look better in
terms of the Outlook than they did
before in terms of reducing the debt
that is definitely going to be one of
his priorities but he has had some good
fortune I've mentioned the fact that it
was a warmer winter than he was
expecting in November but also he's made
some of his Good Fortune because he
stabilized the markets last November and
by stabilizing the market that means
that the amount that the government has
to pay an interest that will be quite a
bit lower than was expected by the
office for Budget responsibility when he
made his statement in November so I
think he will find that he is able to
give some fairly generous measures to
the British public while also focusing
on that long-term debt level coming down
so those are the things spending money
on one of the things that that people
may be interested in is pensions the
government is very keen to get people
back to work so we're seeing
announcements on child care and
announcements on pensions
um for those who don't understand it it
is complicated but if you have a lot of
money and you've managed to Save A Lot
in your pension there's a there's an
upper limit that could be increased we
understand some have said though this is
really just going to affect those who
are are really very well off is is this
something that the government should be
focusing on well I think he's got his
mind on Hospital consultants and
Hospital doctors senior doctors who are
in some of these big public sector
schemes which are very generous uh
compared to what people in the private
sector tend to get these days so I think
you're absolutely right that he will be
looking at work more generally so you
know since the pandemic we have had a
recovery in the economy but there is
still not as many people
um uh who have returned there's more
economic inactivity than there was
before and also there's a lot of
vacancies in the economy and one of the
things that he will be hearing is that
people have retired earlier than they
would do normally because of these
pension limits particularly in the NHS
and he will want to make sure that the
NHS Workforce you know remains uh there
until
later so I think that's one of the
things he will do in fact focus on work
you were covering the child care offer
earlier and that will be to help help
more people return to the workforce
after having a child but
counterintuitive couldn't also be the
case that if you encourage more people
to put more money away
then they could also retire early as
well because they'll put more money away
and so they'll be able to stop working
earlier yeah I think he will have to
look at it in the round and we'll see
what the detail is in the measures
obviously next week on the treasury
committee we'll have in uh be a sort of
official commentators and then we will
have the chancellor himself in front of
the committee we'll be able to Probe on
some of the details but I think the
overall theme will be growing the
economy and helping more people return
to work and taking away some of those
barriers and disincentives that exist in
the benefit and tax system that prevent
people from doing those extra hours
public sector pay big a big subject lots
of strikes today we were told a while
ago that they wouldn't increase the
government wouldn't increase public
sector pay over five percent now being
trailed it could go up to 5.5 percent
the reason that they put that five
percent figure was because they thought
anything over that would fuel inflation
would you be concerned if they announced
a 5.5 increase well it is the Bank of
England's job to keep inflation down and
I I hope that we see the inflation rate
return to uh the bank of England Target
because inflation is obviously the worst
tax on the whole economy it's the worst
tax particularly on the very poorest in
society so it's absolutely essential
that inflation gets back down to its
Target level and I think in that context
the bank of England would not want to
see public sector pay spiraling in line
with inflation because then you get into
what's known as a wage price spiral it
gets much harder to get inflation back
down again realistically what what
impact do you think do you hope that
this budget would have on interest rates
well I think you can hope that it will
continue to calm the markets in the way
that November's statement calm the
markets I think we are in an
inflationary environment it is crucial
that inflation gets back in its box uh
and so it you can't rule out the bank of
England having to raise rates further
than the four percent that they're
currently at but the chancellor will be
very mindful of that with the measures
that he announces today